was haben Sie gedacht als Erdogan
plötzlich völlig überraschend vor diesem
NATO vergipfel Gipfel verkündet dass er
die Blockade gegen den NATO-Beitritt
Schwedens
aufgeben will also nach gestern habe ich
damit nicht mehr gerechnet weil als
Erdogan mit der Idee kamen ja wir nehmen
die in den Weg nach zur EU wieder auf
war das für mich eigentlich
Signal also vergisst es mit Schweden
weil es war klar das wird nicht
passieren ähm die Türkei hat sich ja nun
äh weit von den Werten enorm der EU
entfernt also no way und das er jetzt 24
Stunden danach april April aus der
Spesen nichts gewesen im es geht jetzt
doch
ist so ein bisschen bezahlen also das
einmal öffentlich verkündet warum hat er
das überhaupt so gemacht und das ist
natürlich die große Frage was
ist denn da passiert was hat er dafür
bekommen nicht nur die F16 ähm gewesen
sein was glauben Sie was ist da passiert
hinter den Kulissen tatsächlich ne also
es geht um sicherlich um Visa
Erleichterung es geht vielleicht auch um
also die Waffenlieferung des Paket das
ist muss wohl ausführlicher sein als nur
die F16 und es muss massiver Amerika
kriegt diese Kampfflugzeugen diese
amerikanischen die er sich schon lange
nicht immer so wenn man die das
Verhältnis der der Türkei zu NATO mal
als Historiker eine längeren Perspektive
sieht dass die NATO gar nicht
entscheidend war sondern immer die USA
es ist immer die USA gewesen die die
Türkei in die ein oder andere Richtung
gedrängt hat wenn wir an den Zypern
Konflikt denken nicht der Angriff der
Türkei auf auf Zypern war dann nur
möglich weil die Amerikaner letztlich da
waren gewesen sind und deswegen glaube
ich ist die der Schlüssel mit der
Schlüssel bei beiden zu suchen ne aber
dieser Erleichterung sicherlich auch ein
Punkt also man wird wahrscheinlich ein
Paket geschnürt haben nur trotzdem wird
es ja bezahlen wenn man einmal sagt also
wir machen das nur wenn ihr den Weg in
die EU ja ebnet und das wird es ja auf
gar zumal ich hier auch immer wieder
höre von europapolitikern die sagen das
sagt ja nur dass er die NATO möchte aber
erdogan will in Wahrheit gar nicht in
den EU Entschuldigung ja also es ist
Pizza und das zeigt wie schwer es in der
NATO ist wie man die die Nato hat ja
immer Mitglieder aufgenommen auch aus
politischen Gründen auch aus
geostrategischen Gründen jetzt gar nicht
weil sie vorzeige Demokratien sind also
das klingt ja für die Türkei das gilt
für Griechen Portugal und ähm
was ein Bündnis und die Türkei ist eben
ja ein sehr spezieller
und man will ja natürlich auch die man
kann sie auch übrigens gar nicht
ausschließen weil man musste einstimmig
jemanden ausschließen also das ist gar
nicht vorgesehen bei der NATO okay
jemand auszuschließen also ist man in
diesem in diesem Paket mit drin und
eines der großen Ziele auf den NATO
Gipfeln ist er immer Einigkeit also eine
der zentralen Botschaften ist Einigkeit
Eigentlichkeit und das ist macht das mit
der Türkei natürlich auch Ungarn macht
das nicht einfach sie dürfen sofort der
Brücke also merken sich den Gedanken
würde ich gerne fragen wie kommt das bei
Putin an wie kommt das in Russland an
sie haben viele Drähte dahin nach wie
vor wenn Schweden jetzt plötzlich
Mitglied der NATO wird na gut
sich sich dafür ausspricht auch die
Ukraine in die nato-perspektivisch
aufzunehmen und so weiter also
erstens hat Putin wie wir wie wir sehen
gerade absoluten Gegenteil davon
erreicht was er eigentlich mit diesem
Krieg wollte er wollte keine NATO keine
keine NATO Truppen an den Grenzen haben
jetzt jetzt kriegt das überall jetzt
verstärkt sich also die ganze die ganzen
osteuropäischen Staaten wir wissen was
Polen plant was baltischen Staaten
planen wo schon also was was Mitglied
dauern und so weiter und so fort ja das
ist absoluter Gegenteil ähm
erdogan ist in meinen Augen zum Teilen
Signal er ist natürlich ein absoluter
Wendehals und macht immer diese tän also
Innenpolitik die repressiv ist und
Außenpolitik und gewissen Sinne kann man
haben wir das mit Putin auch verglichen
zum Teil ich glaube also das ist der
verputzen ein Signal der Schwäche weil
Erdogan weil Erdogan was was Erdogan
wahrscheinlich gespürt hat das ist die
Schwäche
der Nationen
nachdem wie dieser Krieg verläuft wie
dieser Krieg in diesen 500 Tagen
verläuft und er braucht und ich glaube
er hat dann weniger Angst von Putin
manchmal man soll diese armenische
aserbaidschanische Geschichte nicht
vergessen und eigentlich hat war
Armenien immer so zögerlich weil man
also eigentlich als ähm erhofft hat
Russland auf der Seite zu haben ja gegen
also gegen
ja klar Gegner als arbeitshan und in dem
Sinne gegen Erdogan aber jetzt ist das
klar dass
Armenien auf keine Unterstützung auf
keine wirkliche Unterstützung und in
diesem Sinne glaube ich fühlt sich
Erdogan irgendwie mehr oder weniger frei
und die schwedische Geschichte ist
natürlich ein Handel also dass das sah
man und überhaupt und Treffen mit
silenski auch davor war natürlich ein
absoluter ein Signal und deine
feierliche Übergabe also von den
Gefangenen von asoph das wiederum unsere
Propaganda auf die Palme gebracht hat
also dass man das nicht angesprochen
sondern ich glaube da sind so Tänze und
ein Zeichen und Puten muss das mehr oder
weniger ernst nehmen das auch diese das
auch diese Figuren also nicht keine
sozusagen und Unterstützung für ihn
gewährleisten können okay
interessante dazu was mit der türkische
Botschaft heute erzählt hat es gibt eine
andere Perspektive auf das was da
passiert ist der sagt es habe keine
Erpressung gegeben Erdogan habe seinen
Wunsch geäußert in die EU Perspektive zu
kommen es gäbe ein neues narrativ diese
neue Amtszeit von Erdogan die wieder
Richtung Europa gehen soll sie haben ja
vom Wendehals gesprochen wir wissen dass
es kaum ein europäisches Land gibt im
Moment das wirklich die Türkei in der EU
haben will aber es sind erste Signale
der Anhörung er distanziert sich von
Putin er kommt Richtung Europa und das
ist interessant er hat jetzt mit
Schweden einen Partner in der EU der in
den nächsten Jahren für die Türkei
kämpfen muss und der wahrscheinlich sich
das ein oder andere daraus verhandelt
hat und das sind nicht nur Visa
Erleichterung das ist auch die Zollunion
also man spielt jetzt gerade wieder mit
einer neuen Nähe Richtung Europa gucken
ob es funktioniert
Marine also die die finden ein großes
her und die Schweden eine Marine eine
sehr moderne Marine und Sie sehen es auf
der Karte Gotland ist geostrategisch von
enormer Bedeutung und die NATO seit 2014
beschäftigt sich damit wie verteidigen
wir eigentlich im Fall der Fälle des
Baltikum also Stichwort zu Wahlkampf
diese Strecke von Belarus nach kalining
gerade die 70 km und viele sagten
Praktikum ist gar nicht zu verteidigen
jetzt haben wir eine völlig andere
geostrategische Situation wir haben
sozusagen einen gewisses strategisches
hinterlanddeckung und die Ostsee wird
wenn ich ganz zu einem mehr der NATO wir
haben noch das Leben auf der Karte ja
auch die ob das Kaliningrad und wir
haben auch noch sagen St Petersburg aber
die geostrategische Situation ist
wirklich sehr viel besser und für
Schweden ist es eine Riesenschritt denn
wir müssen bedenken den letzten Krieg
den die Schweden geführt haben haben sie
zur Zeit in Napoleons geführt also es
kein schwedisch russischen Krieg 1809
bis 12 folgende der letzte wirklich eine
größere Krieg dann immer Neutralität im
19 Jahrhundert im 20 Jahrhundert im
Kalten Krieg also das Schweden in die
NATO kommt also wenn man vor anderthalb
Jahren mir das gesagt hat was haben Sie
denn geraucht also wenn man sie waren
und trotzdem trotzdem eine sehr gut
ausgerüstete
sich immer im Klaren darüber mit wem
sich das zu tun
immer die russische Bedrohung aber es
war nie sagen die Haltung dass man diese
Neutralität auch also eine der ganz
klassischen neutralen Länder und
auch was sie sagten nicht also Putin hat
dass er diese beiden starten die auch
gerüstet sind die auch wehrhaft sind die
finden noch mehr als die fehlen waren
das ist auf jeden Fall eine deutliche
Verschlechterung verboten und sie macht
es danach so leichter diese kleinen
waldischen Stand
ist ja so eine interessante immer wieder
auch in Gesprächen mit Menschen wie
Ihnen immer eines ganz zentrale Rolle
ist ja also das Mallorca von Schweden
wenn man so ein bisschen will wenn man
jetzt dahin fährt ist das Leben leicht
und schön und wunderbar und schöne
schwedische Familien machen dort Urlaub
ist alles schöne Menschen hat man immer
den Eindruck und Essen gutes Essen und
alles ist wunderbar und dann finden aber
gleichzeitig so Geheimtreffen statt und
Geheimdienst der tummeln sich da und
Pippi Langstrumpf Haus ist auch noch um
die Ecke die Villa Kunterbunt und so
völlig verrückte Welt aber das ist ja
interessant dass wir eigentlich seit
2014 ähm schwenkt die NATO ja auf
Planung um was würde eigentlich
passieren wenn Russland nach der Lektion
der Krim nach dem Dom was nach dem
Baltikum greift und seitdem haben wir ja
eine eine presents diese bataione und so
weiter also die NATO planst und wenn wir
in Berlin Köln Hamburg München Magdeburg
wo immer auf die Straße gehen leben wir
unser Leben das sind ganz andere Fragen
Klimaschutz und so relevant aber im
Hintergrund läuft das natürlich weil die
sich vorbereiten müssen wir sehen ja
auch Februar 22 wir können eine
Wehrhaftigkeit oder eine
Verteidigungsfähigkeit nicht einfach aus
dem Hut zaubern sondern braucht es lange
lange Vorbereitung und ist Probleme
dabei also von daher ist ein wichtiger
Schritt echt ein einen eine Wegmarke
jetzt auch für die Geschichte Schwedens
und
für die Nato und gut so diese 4000 Mann
Bundeswehr in Litauen eine Brigade ja
die wir jetzt historius hat das jetzt
versprochen und dass die dauerhaft
stationiert und das war wirklich ein
Paukenschlag denn der Bundeskanzler hat
das ja schon angedeutet dann ruderte man
zurück und sagte naja nur ein Stab und
die Liter haben natürlich gesagt und
dann unser eigenes Geschichte erinnert
ähm der Bundesrepublik in der ist ja
viele ausländische Gäste gaben im Kalten
Krieg also die Kanadier waren da die
Amerikaner die Briten die Niederländer
und so weiter und wir hatten überhaupt
keinen moralischen Grund zu sagen der
der Westen hat uns geschützt mit
Soldaten
und jetzt wollen die Litauen dasselbe
mit welchem informiert sagen Nein und
natürlich war aus organisatorischen
Gründen ich verstehe das auch dass das
hier eines um Gottes Willen der müssen
wir die stationieren was heißt denn das
jetzt müssen wir vielleicht Standorte
zumachen wir haben ja nicht einmal eine
Brigade lieber dahin schicken können ja
wollen wir die jetzt aus aus Torgelow
dahin verlegen dann kommen natürlich die
bundestagsabkommen und sagen meine
Kaserne bitte nicht dich suchen genau
weil davon lebt die ganze Probleme
Infrastruktur und deswegen sagte man
lieber nee lieber nicht es einfacher so
und dass der Verteidigungsminister
meines Erachtens war das aus politischen
Gründen der richtige Schritt ich würde
auch aus dem militärischen Gründen so
argumentieren und dass er gesagt hat ich
mache das ist ihm glaube ich sehr hoch
anzurechnen weil wir werden als
auszustehen mir sagen ja immer also
toler reden und schön aber was kommt
denn jetzt ne also entscheidend ist ja
immer die Tat was wird denn wirklich
gemacht in der in der Politik und das
war eine fand ich zumindest einen
beachtlicher der auch ihm glaube ich das
Leben auf der Bundesregierung auf dem
Gipfel leicht gemacht die
Bundesregierung ist vorgegangen kann man
jetzt sagen die Rumänen zu den Franzosen
wir wollen auch noch Brigade haben und
da ist jetzt wirklich mal die
Bundesrepublik vor der Welle ja und und
segelt nicht hinterher also ich finde
das beachtlich positiv beachtlichen
ich erinnere mich an ich glaube Florence
gaub war es die hier war Herr Brücker
die sagte muss ich das klar machen es
ist ein riesiger Unterschied ob da 20
oder 50 Mann sind oder ob wir plötzlich
ernsthaft wenn es passiert wenn die
wirklich angreifen da war der 24 Februar
sozusagen die die die Zäsur dann muss
man sofort reagieren dann kann man nicht
in Berlin oder woanders erstmal Soldaten
anfangen langsam ins Baltikum zu
schaffen das heißt mit anderen Worten
wir werden überhaupt quer durch Europa
jetzt eine bis an die Zähne bewaffnete
Grenze haben einen neuen eisernen
auf diesem Gipfel wird ja wenn ja auch
die perspektivisch meine ich jetzt
glaube ich auch nicht wir werden ja
diese regional defence Plans die jetzt
verabschiedet werden muss sind zum
ersten Mal dass die NATO anfängt
unser erste Pläne zu machen was passiert
denn jetzt konkret wenn wenn es ein
Angriff auf Polen auf Rumänien auf das
Baltikum gäbe und das wir sind noch
nicht vom Kalten Krieg da gab es ja in
für jede Brücke für jede Stellung das
war ausgemessen da gab es Gruppen und im
Kalten Krieg hatten wir ja
hunderttausende Soldaten in der
Bundesrepublik und der das werden wir da
nicht sehen also die die Truppen haben
wir gar nicht die Deutschen hatten im
Kalten Krieg 12 Division 500.000 Mann
jetzt reden über eine Brigade über 4.000
ja also es ist ähm immer noch bescheiden
aber der Gegner ist natürlich auch ein
anderer und es ist nicht mehr da
Warschau Park das ist nicht mehr so wird
Union aber dass man sagt wir müssen
schon auch vorne ernsthaft verteidigen
war ein politisches Statement das
Solidarität diese bataione aus vielen
Nationen das war so ein Trip wir ja ein
Stolperdraht die eins die
berlin-brigaden und jetzt kommt aber der
Schritt mit Pistolen nein wir haben da
ein Kampfverband der auch wirklich
kämpfen kann
dauerhaft da und damit werden deutsche
Soldaten in großer Zahlen dauerhaft
außerhalb des Landes das ist auch was
anderes als in Kirche
10 km über der Grenze ist das etwas
auch im Kabinett im politischen Berlin
auch ihre grüne Partei die ja nun auch
aus der Friedensbewegung sozusagen kommt
ist das etwas was im Bauchschmerzen
macht wenn Sie diese Entwicklung sehen
ich finde es erstmal eine atemberaubende
Beschreibung über wenige Jahre
Jahrzehnte die sie eben geben vom Kalten
Krieg von der blockkonzentration über
das was wir mit Fall des Eisernen
Vorhangs der friedlichen Revolution und
ein paar Jahren wo wir dachten wir
brauchen so was nicht mehr vollzogen
haben wir wir sitzen kennen das alle wir
haben das mitgemacht jüngere kennen das
nicht und jetzt eine Beschreibung über
diesen NATO-Gipfel der ja auch ein Stück
weit atemberaubend ist was dort an
Entscheidungen an jetzt kurzfristiger
Hilfe für die Ukraine ganz aktueller
akuter militärischer Hilfe für die
Ukraine beschlossen wird in einer großen
Einigkeit ich glaube ohne 700 Millionen
kontroverse Diskussion 700 Millionen aus
Deutschland aus dem deutschen
Bundeshaushalt letzten Endes und dann
aber halt auch weitreichende
strategische Entscheidungen die sie eben
beschrieben haben die möglicherweise die
viel größere Bedeutung haben und das ist
ein Wandel also wer das irgendwie jetzt
völlig auf die leichte Schulter nimmt
und sagt das wäre völlig normal das ist
glaube ich in keiner Partei vorhanden
ist nicht interessanter Brücker dass
sagen was die Grünen angeht dort
deutlich mehr Klarheit herrscht als
beispielsweise in der SPD ja man muss
sich schon positiv wundern über die
Wandlung der Grünen bei dem Thema in den
letzten anderthalb Jahren nicht ich
erlebe ja kaum noch grüne
Spitzenpolitiker die diese Art von Härte
auch militärpolitische abschreckender
Härte nicht gut und richtig finden und
vielleicht ist es gerade wenn man aus so
einer Vergangenheit kommt wie die Grünen
ist die Tragweite schneller zu erkennen
weil ich teile eigentlich ihre Analyse
dass wir da eine neue einen neuen Kalten
Krieg am Ende vielleicht ein frozen an
dieser Perspektive
Konflikt dann irgendwann mal sein und
wir haben diese Menschen da und die
tausende Soldaten haben wir nicht viele
ausländischen einsetzen man muss sofort
an Afghanistan denken und was haben wir
diskutiert über Jahre über diese
Einsätze und jetzt haben wir ein ganz
neuen dauerhaften Auslandseinsatz das
macht schon was mit mit dem Land glaube
ich und dass die Grünen sich das
vielleicht auch historisch gewachsen so
schnell auch andere wergeheftet haben
hut ab man muss ja nur mal die Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz im Februar 2022
sehen als Angeln in der baerbock
wahrscheinlich sagen musste
ja wir können keine Waffen liefern aus
historischen Gründen mich nicht immer
fragte was denn für historische Gründe
eigentlich ne haben wir nicht selber die
die Ukraine überfallen im Zweiten
Weltkrieg und so egal das war ja immer
so zu wie wir wir stehen uns da draußen
oder wir kennen ja Habichts Trip
sozusagen nach in die Ukraine und die
defensiv im Sommer davor und dieser
Wandel da würde ich dann sagte wir
sollten den helfen sie richtig richtig
Ärger und das ist eine
ein Wandel und es gab ja auch dann
Umfragen die Diskussion panzerlieferung
und da waren ja wesentlich mehr grüne
Wähler für die panzerlieferung als bei
der CDU also in gewiss ein bestimmtes
CDU ähm überholt und das ist schon
beachtet wenn wir noch haben
wir haben ja uns geweigert fünf Drohnen
zu bewaffnen nicht diese absurde Debatte
der SPD vor allem
wo man sich
greift und nein man wollte das nicht
also da gibt es schon wenn man sie wo
Deutschland herkommt
ja weil es ging ja um etwas weil es ging
ja ganz eindeutig es ging verzeihen Sie
mir wenn ich ganz banal sagt es ging um
Menschenrechte und um Demokratie
gegründet
katastrophalerweise und deshalb muss man
ja keinen anderen Ausweg und irgendwie
und was wir erlebt haben
das Argumente schon vorher gesehen
das ist die ganze Zeit als Grund dieses
Krieges erklärt wie wir Putin sagt ja
die ganze Zeit wir kämpfen gegen den
besten und gegen die Werte und gegen
diese falsche die gegen diese falsche
europäische Werte und ich glaube das war
deshalb absolut unvermeidbar bei den bei
den Grünen die die eigentlich das alles
unterstützen müssen es ist nur die Frage
warum wir sind warum wir alle dort
geraten wo dort geraten sind wo wir wo
wir uns befinden dass wir wirklich so
rüsten müssen so sich bewaffnen müssen
und es gibt keinen anderen Ausweg und
wenn wir diese Geschichte also sozusagen
diese von diesen 500 Tagen rückwärts
sehen würden also die sah so kläglich am
Anfang aus erstmal so zögerlich
politische Entscheidungen
dann als politische Entscheidung halt
getroffen haben habe es herausgestellt
dass mit den technischen Entscheidungen
also irgendwie so schwer glaubt eines
funktioniert nicht das andere ist nicht
da also das und es ist sozusagen also
diese ganze nato-geschichte war ein
bisschen Papiertiger nun
sich in den Augen von Puten und dann
plötzlich diese Bilder voll im gerade
das Foto gesehen haben von Anton
Hofreiter und Robert Habeck die da auf
dem Balkon irgendwo stehen
was so leise im Hintergrund oder gab es
in Wahrheit heftige Debatten die sie
Geschlossenheit der Grünen die hat mich
immer erstaunt dann hat er das Gefühl da
passt argumentativ kein Blatt dazwischen
es gab die heftigen Auseinandersetzungen
ich würde sagen vor dem 24 Februar das
haben sie auch ein Stück weit
geschrieben und das waren ja nicht die
Grünen alleine sondern zu begreifen was
ich dort in dem Krieg der natürlich
vorher schon geführt wurde von Russland
gegen die Ukraine aber was ich dort
verändert hatte mit einem so
offensichtlichen und ja
unverschämten und
Ansage an sämtliche Nachkriegsordnung
weltfriedensordnung die wir
zwischenzeitlich hatten anders Erbe vom
Fall des Eisernen Vorhangs das war ein
Paradigmenwechsel der sich dort uns in
der deutschen Politik vollzogen hat und
ab diesem Zeitpunkt gab es glaube ich in
allen Parteien veränderte Sichtweisen
veränderte
Entscheidungsstrukturen des Kurse und
möglicherweise ist das bei uns dann
schneller vonstatten gegangen eben weil
es um Menschenrechte um den
Freiheitskampf der Ukraine gegangen ist
aber eben auch um das komplette
ignorieren konfrontieren eines
souveränen Staates von nationalen
Grenzen und dem Verschieben von das was
die Nachkriegsordnung gewesen ist was
darauf spricht ist immer noch sozusagen
dieses Entsetzen über das was da
passiert ist und fortschärfer hat gerade
finde ich zu Recht darauf hingewiesen
jetzt stehen wir da bis an die Zähne
bewaffnet haben eine Region mitten in
Europa wo Waffen in einer Konzentration
zu finden sind wie sie lange nicht so
sehen waren und die Kollegen aus der
Regie können das vielleicht mal zu
spielen und sie erleichtern uns einmal
was das ist Streumunition
also wenn man das sieht was diese Art
von Munition kann dann wird er Angst und
lange was ist das genau
ja als strömmunition sehen wir hier in
dem mit dem mit dem Bomben sehr schön
gelten
Sprengkörper die sich in
Sub sprengen Körper aufteilen hunderte
tausende genau und damit eine relativ
auf eine relativ große Fläche wirken
können das ist eigentlich eine relativ
alte Form es gibt schon in der frühen
Neuzeit die Wehrmacht hat sowas
eingesetzt im Zweiten Weltkrieg ähm
jetzt hat jede große Armee das und das
Problem dieser Munition ähm sind die
Blindgänger also die blindgängerquoten
dieser dieser kleinen Körper so ziemlich
hoch 30 % 40 %, und man hat dann gemerkt
dass in den Gebieten wo das abgeworfen
wird
eigentlich wie mieten ja das verseucht
ist und sehr oft dann Zivilisten die
dort leben ähm zu Tode kommen schwer
verletzt werden und deswegen gab es dann
nach 1990 eine große Bewegung die
Personen gebannt hat und auch diese
diese Streumunition nicht
110 Staaten das muss man aber dazu sagen
wir sind im 2010 in einer völlig anderen
Welt gewesen 2010 dachten wir so einen
Krieg wie er jetzt vorkommt genau das
gibt es gar nicht mehr also in Europa
das große Armee gegeneinander kämpfen
sondern was wir haben waren diese
sogenannten out of area Einsätze dass
die NATO die europäischen Staaten
Afghanistan Mali Irak und so weiter und
das natürlich in diesen Regionen ganze
Landstriche wenn sie eingesetzt waren
eben im unzugänglich waren die
zielbevölkerung aber natürlich ist es
wie wie in vielen anderen Bereichen
Atomwaffen und so weiter dass die großen
militärstaaten Deutschland ist
unterzeichnet hat auch keine Träume
Nation mehr aber
Russland auch die Ukraine im China die
USA haben das nicht anders nicht
unterschrieben so eine rote Linie über
die man da geht also Streuung setzen die
Russen das ein in der Ukraine muss
eingesetzt und die Ukraine haben es auch
eingesetzt und Alter das wird schon
Munition und ich würde immer zu sagen
naja man muss sich immer sehr genau
sehen um was geht es jetzt die die
Amerikaner haben gesagt sie liefern
Artilleriegranaten den Ukraine aus denen
man diese streummunition verschießen
kann und du musst also erstmal es ist
die Entscheidung der Ukraine ist auf
ihrem eigenen Territorium einzusetzen
und die Ukraine ist natürlich ein
erhebliche Maße vermiet also bereits von
den russischen von den Russen in diesen
Abwehrstellungen also das Argument wir
bringen jetzt diese Blindgänger
der Amerikaner sagen diese Munition hat
weniger Blindgänger aber da ist viel
Propaganda dabei wir müssen immer noch
von oben blindgängerquote ausgehen ja
wenn man die einsetzt sind bestimmte
Bereiche
für Zwiebel Bevölkerung nicht begehbar
aber das ist ohnehin so und für die
Ukraine geht es jetzt meine Sachen da
drin
also die Ukraine kämpfte wir überleben
und diese Frage für mich ist dieser
Krieg nicht entschieden die Frage ist
gibt es den ukrainischen Staat noch in
zwei Jahren oder nicht und wenn jetzt
geht es darum dass man das die Ukraine
versuchen diese Verteidigungsanlagen zu
durchbrechen und das militärische
Argument ist diese Munition kann bei dem
gräbensystem uns helfen dabei und
deswegen würde ich mich schwer tun einem
Ukrainer zu sagen nein das darfst du
nicht verwenden weil also es ist zwar
moralisch das höhere Gewicht dann wird
er sagen Aachen haben sich schon beide
Seiten eingesetzt wir sind ja im Prinzip
rechtlich nicht gebunden weil beide
starten sich unterschrieben haben und
wir müssen immer sehen also für uns ist
das hier bequem in Hamburg aber dieser
Staat in diese Menschen kämpfen um zu
überleben und das ist das diese
besondere Situation die es zu bedenken
gilt
vor da unten ist ein Schützengraben ich
meine das das ist ein unvorstellbares
Blumen vergießen
aber kein Krieger bestimmt
wirklich ausdrücken es geht um kämpfen
töten und sterben und wir haben uns
wirklich wir haben wirklich in uns sein
angewöhnt auch nachvollziehbarer Weise
diese schlimmen Dinge des Krieges ist
tot den Tod rauszudeklinieren wir haben
auch gedacht dass wir bei
Auslandseinsätzen wir tun nur das Gute
und so weiter das ist immer eine
Illusion es gibt keinen guten Kriege ja
und wissen Sie also was wir natürlich
wir wir sagen dass immer wieder aber
wenn man also diese Bilder sieht
es ist ein unglaublicher Krieg gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung und neue Dings also
sind wiederum die Zahlen laut geworden
also 9000 Zivilisten nur darunter
hunderte von Kindern also jeden Tag also
werden irgendwelche Häuser in der
Ukraine also das ist ein
das ist ein Vernichtungskrieg was wir am
Anfang dieses Krieges gesehen haben ist
es absolut eine absoluter Horror mit mit
also wir wissen ja übrigens und wie viel
es wirklich Zivilisten gefallen sind
wissen wir ja noch nicht nicht weil weil
was dort in den besetzten Gebieten sich
abgespielt hat also deshalb also es ist
ja wirklich absolut dieser Krieg hat
vieles also die ganz Sicherheitssysteme
also NATO Regeln in meinen Augen alles
auf den Kopf gestellt und auf eine sehr
harte Prüfung und wenn es am Anfang
dieses Krieges um kugelsichere Westen
gehen wo wir uns immer daran erinnern ja
Schutzhelme jetzt geht es um endlich um
Kampfflugzeuge weil es ist ja es ist ja
absolut klar dass also dass der Ukraine
seinen also diese Offensive ja ohne ohne
diese Flieger gar nicht schaffen manche
sagen als nächster Schritt kommt kommt
kampfgas oder so das hört sich auch
schon mal und das ist also ich würde die
streumulation jetzt wirklich nicht mit
mit Giftgas in einem Topf schmeißen da
müssen wir also nochmal meine Empfehlung
ist immer jeder kann das moralisch
bewerten
wir wirklich
konkret eingesetzt und kann es der
Ukraine Vorteil geben und dann kann man
kann man die laden
was anderes wenn man wenn man das
einfach nur hört und ich ich schaue mir
auch vieles dazu an und so weiter und
dann hört man dass da 10.000 Menschen
dann einfach wieder zusammengezogen
werden aber da noch mal 10.000 und da
noch mal 10.000 die Russen sagen wir
brauchen nochmal 20.000 und die Ukraine
halten so unterwegs wie jedes Mal das
ist jedes Mal ein Mensch ein Leben eine
Familie die da dran hängt und so weiter
verstehen sie und da geht diese
Streumunition runter und dann weißt du
das Sterben jetzt nicht sehen da sterben
wenn da 200 sind die alle weg ne so wenn
die Strom nicht einsetzt sterben sie
wenn sie mal sehen Soldaten
mörderische Spirale in die wieder
reingeraten sind kämpfen töten Sterben
der Wesens Bestandteil eines Krieges es
gibt immer noch Unterschiede sonst
würden ja auch nicht die andere Seite
das machen was die Russen im Butcher
gemacht haben also wir müssen es immer
auch noch mal differenzieren dürfen ich
finde den einzigen kritischen Punkt
daran eigentlich erstens 130 Länder ist
nicht wenig es gab einen guten Grund
oder oder zehn Länder es gibt keinen
guten Grund warum das geächtet wurde und
auch im Krieg gibt es noch Regen selbst
wenn sich eine Seite nicht und der
andere viel schwierigere Punkt aus
meiner Sicht nun meine gegen These ist
dass die Unterstützung für die
Mitwirkung wenn man ehrlich ist oder
oder die Waffenlieferung singt in den
westlichen demokratischen Ländern wenn
wir ähnliche Schritte gehen wie es die
Russen tun und diese Unterstützung ist
auch Kuschel für die ukrainischen
Soldaten denn die Mehrheit dieser
Waffensysteme die jetzt gerade noch
benutzt werden das 16 Monaten sind
westliche Waffen wenn die nicht mehr
kommen weil es in den USA Debatten
darüber geht oder in Deutschland oder in
Frankreich oder England dann haben die
ukrainischen Soldaten auch nichts mehr
davon weil die Unterstützung gesunken
ist weil wir sowas jetzt einsetzen das
hat auch immer darüber nicht diskutieren
glaube ich also
das wissen sie doch gar nicht die
diskutieren jetzt schon darüber Trump
wird sein Wahlkampf machen was haben wir
in der Ukraine zu verlassen aber das ist
aber damit nicht genau
ich fand interessant wie Frau Lemke von
argumentierte aus ihrer Zeit als
Generalsekretärin und sagte da geht zum
zuspitzen da geht zum Polarisierung
die Sprache die man mäßigen muss sie
haben gerade zitiert was da in
Sachsen-Anhalt geredet wird und so
weiter
die die
diese Geschichte lenkt ja Brücke ein
bisschen ab von dem was auch gerade hier
in den politisch passiert und wird wenn
ich noch ein Argument einwerfen darf zu
der Streumunition weil ich glaube es ist
richtig dass wir das nicht moralisch
richten dürfen wir sind nicht
Kriegspartei die USA werden sich
entscheiden zu liefern das teile ich
aber ich bin sehr bei Hamburger und ich
finde dass dieser ganze Vorgang zeigt
wichtig ist gewesen wäre diese Munition
weltweit und für alle Staaten zu echten
und ich finde das sollte als Ziel
bestehen bleiben dass man versucht
solche Abkommen auch in Zukunft weiter
durchzusetzen damit solche Waffen nicht
eingesetzt werden und die Frage ist ja
auch wenn wir argumentieren Russland
setzt Streu Munition ein und deshalb ist
es legitim das auch die Ukraine
streuemunition einsetzt wohin führt das
genau diese diese kritischen Fragen
müssen wir aushalten ich glaube wir
haben darauf heute Abend alle keine
abschließenden Antworten aber Sie müssen
wenigstens gestellt werden